الف مبروك لافضل من لمس الكره في التاريخ
هذه وجهه نظر شخصيه وكل انسان له وجهه نظر
وجهه نظر الشخصيه انه ميسي هو افضل لاعب
في تاريخ كره القدم بدون جدال ولا نقاش
ولازم يعترف بهذه الحقيقه
الجميع يتحدث عن دييغو ارماندو مارادونا
وعن انجاز 1986 وانه حمل الارجنتين على
اكتافه نعم وهذا صحيح
مارادونا في تلك البطوله صنع خمسه اهداف
وسجل خمسه اهداف ميسي اليوم صار صانع
اربعه اهداف ومسجل اربعه اهداف يعني هدفين
وبيوصل لرقم مارادونا بس 86 ولكن مع فرق
بسيط انه ميسي اليوم ما معه فلنه معه
جوليان الفارس اللي اكتشفناه بهذه البطوله
واللي حرفيا اثبت انه هو اللاعب اللي كان
لازم يعتمد عليه اسكالوني من البدايه
الفارس اللاعب اللي بيبدا الهجمه الفارس
اللاعب اللي بيضغط الفارس اللاعب اللي
بيسجل جوليا الفارس هو المهاجم اللي بتقدر
تعتمد عليه بكل هذه الادوار داخل ارضيه
الملعب وداخل المنظومه ولاجمل من جولان
الفارس هو رد فعل لو تاره مرتينوس لما
تبدل جولان الفارس اول واحد راح لعنده
يسلم عليه هو لو تاره مرتينز وهيروح
الفريق الي نحن عم نحكي عنه وهذا الشيء
اللي لازم يتعلموا منه اللاعبين العرب
وغير العرب بكل امانه جولان الفارس اخذ
محله وثاره بك كاس العالم ورغم ذلك ما كان
في اي مشكله بالموضوع اسكالون اليوم معك
ما لعب بشكل انه انا الارجنتين وما بصير
دافع امام كرواتيا بالعكس تماما تسلم
دقائق المباراه تقريبا وصل استحوات 53% و
54% وكان معتمد على الهجمات المرتده كان
معتمد على انه يضرب المنتخب الكرواتي
بالكرات المرتده السريعه وهو ما نجح في
بالضبط نجح في في ثلاثه مناسبات
وهي نقطه تحسب اسكالوني والاكثر من هيك
انه
لعب بنفس الاسلوب امام هولندا لا غير
اسلوب
عند الدقيقه تقريبا بالخمسينات اول 60 دخل
لساندرو مارتينز ورجع على طريق اللاعب
اللي هي 3 5 2 او 5 3 2 سمي هاما شئت
تبديلات اسكالوني طريقه ادارته للمباراه
كانت رائعه جدا اليوم بالمقابل زلاتكو
داليتش كان عنده اخطاء كبيره اول هاي
الاخطاء لما عندك مهاجم مثل بيتكوفيتش
اثبت حاله من بدايه البطوله اليوم على انه
واحد من افضل مهاجمين بالنسبه للمنتخب
الكرواتي ليش ما صرت لعب كره اساسي اكيد
هو عنده سبب ولكن انا شخصيا مش عارف هذا
السبب بيكون امانه
اللاعب الموجود على الجهه اليمنى اللي هو
فصل نفس العمليه كمان اورسيتش لما دخل غير
شكل الفريق هجوميه وصارت كرواتيا اخطر عن
مرمى الارجنتيني وكانت قادره انها تسجل
الهدف ربما تعود بالمباراه
فطريقه اللي دخل فيها زلاتكو دالتش كانت
خاطئه وهذا بالضبط بيوضح ليش الارجنتين
تفوقت اليوم على كرواتيا بوضح ان المنتخب
الارجنتيني داخل هاي البطوله بروح تحقيق
لقب بروح الانتصار بروح على انه عازمين
على اعطائها البطوله ليونيل ميسي قبل
الاعتزال وعندهم الادوات اللي بتخليهم
فعلا قادرين يوصلوا لهذا الهدف لاعب الاخر
لازم تشيت في اليوم هو تاليفيكو وتاليا
فيكم اللي لعب بديلا
لكونيا كونيا المصاب طبعا وتاليا في كل
يوم كان ممتاز جدا بعمليه افتكاك الكره
كان ممتاز جدا بعمليه لزيادات الهجوميه
وكان ممتاز ايضا بعمليه التعامل مع
الهجمات الكرواتيه من الجهه اليسرى عن
طريق ايران وفيتش او
ايا كان اللاعب يكون على الجهه اليمنى
للمنتخب الكرواتي طريقه بصراحه وتبديل
باريس ما استغربته لانه فريديس يعني
بصراحه ما له اي دور كبير غير انه بيبدا
الهجمه بالمنتخب الارجنتيني ما عدا ذلك
باريس بارو جدا محدوده مع الارجنتين ولكن
عامه اليوم المنتخب الارجنتيني قدم مباراه
كبيره وكان لازم يبلش بهذه الطريقه الجميل
في منتخب الارجنتين انه رايح تصاعدي كل
مباراه بتتحسن على المباراه اللي قبلها
وبصير اهدا واكثر نضجا داخل ارضيه الملعب
في فرق كبير بين هذه المباراه هولندا من
ناحيه النضج والعقليه وهو المطلوب لتحقيق
اللقب بالنهايه مبروك لجماهير المنتخب
الارجنتيني ميسي على ابواب تحقيق اللقب
واخيرا ولكن ما بننسى انه على الطرف الاخر
في فرنسا وفي المغرب وبعد العمليه
بالميدان يا حميدان فخلينا نشوف شو راح
يصير بالنهائي حتى الان هل الارجنتين اول
الفرق المتاهله الى نهائي كاس العالم 2022
فقط
[موسيقى]